le midi vous trouverez souvent aux
différents marchés de versailles
un camion citroën tout de vert vêtu à
l'intérieur deux yvelinois qui prône le
flexitarisme une alimentation que peu de
gens connaissent le flexitarisme c'est
quoi c'est simplement de manger de
manière raisonnable et raisonné donc
manger de la viande de temps en temps et
quand on en mange de qualité donc issus
d'une production responsable tout
simplement ancien collègue devenu ami
alexander et antonine avec une enveloppe
de 1500 euros en poche pour lancer le
projet la maison de l'entreprise de
saint quentin en yvelines a soutenu leur
démarche en leur apportant soutien et
aide financière pour un prêt total
auprès des banques de 60000 euros
anthony lui était responsable de la
partie hôtellerie mois de la partie
restauration
on a vu qu'on pouvait gérer ensemble
une entreprise et donc on se dit
pourquoi pas faire la nôtre
leur concept se trouve entre le fast
food et la nourriture saine avec 4
burger à la carte dont la moitié sont
végétariens mais en automne donc on
essaye de cas récents articles
autographes pour faire un portobello
c'est un gros champignon c'est plus aux
champignons comestibles qui remplace le
steak tout simplement ça qui marche pas
mal
c'est donc l'autre 7 c'est à falafel a
revisité en fait que confère la plancha
au lieu de faire la pole
le soir le camion s'installe dans
différentes villes alentour et malgré
leur confinement
la clientèle est au rendez vous le dis
comme ça s'arrête le jeudi soir sur la
place principale de saint cyr l'école et
et c'est là où pour la première fois je
vais commander je vais manger chez moi
et ses idoles a trouvé ça excellent pour
une première année
ouais ouais c'est carrément au delà de
nos espérances c'est un bon présage pour
l'avenir
le food truck change de lieu selon les
jours pour savoir où le trouver il
suffit d'aller vérifier sur leur site
internet